e aí
o pé em 1997 há 22 anos atrás uma banda
em são paulo lá da periferia de capão
redondo lança o cd que é basicamente o
auge dessa dessa musicalidade na região
esse cd é considerado um dos 100
melhores álbuns da música brasileira
eleito pela revista rolling stones que é
uma revista especializada em música e se
algo rendeu a marca de um milhão e meio
de cópias vendidas em 1997 é considerado
um dos grandes marcos da música
brasileira sendo assim ele tem um grande
impacto não só na questão cultural mas
principalmente na questão social dos
lugares e levar em consideração que o
racionais naquela época naquele lugar a
ele não trabalhava com grandes vídeos
televisão não participava de grandes
programas televisivos não participava de
grandes programas de rádio não tinha
grande mídia atrás deles e mesmo assim
alcançou esse
um mar de vendas e
e imaginemos como isso pode ser possível
a música deles representava o que a
galera da periferia sentia a turma da
periferia via e era representativa a
eles essa representação significava a
música em outro patamar era uma poesia
para eles e isso essa transformação que
acaba tendo dessa música ea reprodução
disso faz passando de comunidade
comunidade até chegar essa grande
importância nacional que se algum teve
tamanho é importância que no vestibular
da unicamp agora de que vai ser de 2022
esse álbum está listado em obras
literárias unicamp como gênero poesia o
tamanho que a importância levando isso
em consideração que em 1997 à internet
no brasil engatinhava
e a possibilidade dessas redes pessoais
comunicação era muito alta e isso
ocasionou essa esse tamanho alcance esse
algo na cara em caráter nacional a
internet propriamente dita só vai ter
uma uma certa abrange missa no brasil a
partir dos anos 2000 com maior
desenvolvimento e aprofundamento das
tecnologias digitais de informação e
comunicação essas diversas tecnologias
como sendo desenvolvidos não só no
brasil mas do mundo todo e aplicados e
país como o brasil durante todo o século
21 no início dos anos2000 à internet no
brasil era bem devagar se muito deve-se
lembrar que para se conectar você quando
estava na linha telefônica se escutar o
barulho do modem tinha horários
específicos
em finais de semana e tinha que ficar
tomando conta para ver se ninguém tirar
o telefone do gancho
e hoje a banda larga ela existe no
brasil como como algo até comum apesar
de que ela não atinge todo o território
nacional como espera-se que atingiria
nós temos dados a dentro do território
nacional de que isso vai ser vai atingir
pouco mais de sessenta por cento do
território brasileiro as pessoas com
acesso pouco mais de sessenta por cento
levando em consideração a países
desenvolvidos com o país da europa que
sim essa margem chega 84 por cento em
países mais desenvolvidos ainda como
inglaterra frança alemanha e se passa
dos 90 porcento e nas américas no
continente americano a margem cerca de
64 por cento nos estados unidos também
chega bem mais de 80 com que isto se dá
no brasil
e há uma falta de kid a de
infraestrutura adequada para ser
transmitida isso o nosso território além
disso o alto valor também pede a essa
grande conectividade por esta nação
saindo um pouco a desse macro espectro
passando agora para os pequenos lugares
como o centros que nós trabalhamos de
transmissão de conhecimento de saber
como nas escolas nós temos outros dados
interessantes
e a foi considerada para a partir da
prova do índice de pizza que é uma prova
que vai mensurar educação a qualidade de
educação a nível mundial cerca de 28,3
por cento dos alunos principalmente de
escolas públicas aqui dizem afirmaram
que usam internet nas escolas a grande
maioria não uso e que a maioria dos
alunos entrevistados eles afirmaram que
preferem utilizar sem internet em casa
por qual razão essa internet não é
utilizada nas escolas aí nós podemos
levantar alguns vários fatores de forma
rápida primeiro a falta dessa
infraestrutura
e nas escolas a falta desses aparelhos
dessas desses artefatos tecnológicos
dentro das escolas e à falta também de
uma formação específica dos professores
e dos técnicos ao trabalharem essa
tecnologia dentro das escolas em países
desenvolvidos em países desenvolvidos
esse número é muito alto nós já citamos
que em países como a inglaterra acesso
da população chega mais de oitenta por
cento e noventa porcento nas escolas é o
mesmo
ah mas por que que nós estamos citando a
internet nesse caso dentro dos aspectos
escolares através da internet novas
relações vão aparecer novas
configurações dos modelos sociais
começam a transference na nossa nossa
contemporaneidade surge então nesse
universo ou seja nesse cyber-espaço esse
grande universo virtual uma nova
categoria de análise do que se é
produzido pelas pessoas no no dia a dia
as agricultura a servir cultura nada
mais é aqui essa transformação do que se
produz na realidade de forma cultural de
forma intelectual científica artística é
transportado isso para o universo
virtual e essa produção reprodução
transmissão retransmissão e significação
desse conteúdo pode ser acessado em
qualquer lugar no mundo
e nas agricultura não existe barreiras
não existem fronteiras não existe nenhum
tipo de barreira geográfica que vai
impedir que se acesse esse conhecimento
se acesse esse produto cultural e
intelectual que é produzido em qualquer
lugar do mundo daí voltando a ideia de
que a maior parte dos alunos no brasil
usam e acesso à internet em casa
e aí dá uns pensar que tipo de
conhecimento esses alunos estão obtendo
porque é muito fácil a gente pesar mas a
usar celular nas escolas a tecnologia
nas escolas não para quem é professor e
tá na no ensino básico entendi uma coisa
a tecnologia ela existe e se faz
presente dentro da escola dentro dos
processos educativos dentro da sala de
aula a gente querendo ou não
de uma forma ou de outras tecnologias
digitais elas existem e muitos material
didático de escolas particulares por
exemplo eles trabalham essencialmente
com uma parte virtual
e os cursos de educação à distância
também existem para isso trabalhar tem
então as tecnologias existem a nós
lutarmos contra essa tecnologia digital
nas escolas é uma batalha que a gente
perdeu não adianta pensar dessa forma o
ideal é pensar como trabalhar junto com
isso então quando nós vemos os nossos
alunos saindo das escolas indo para suas
casas ou em qualquer outro ambiente fora
as escolas vão até no pátio das escolas
a eles procuram o conhecimento que eles
vão acessar isso a partir de qual ponto
de vista do que estão conhecendo os seus
colegas do que é mais cômico do que
fácil e aí vocês através do youtubers
vão acessar através de instagramers de
qualquer pessoa que pode produzir um
tipo de saber se nenhum critério senão
critério caráter metodológico até mesmo
científico por quê
a crítica muita questão da ciência não
se produz isso com esses critérios a
maioria desses conhecimentos que os
alunos vão atrás eles sabem de cor e
salteado o nome dos youtubers o que ele
produz o que ele fala muitas vezes não
têm acesso diretamente ao conhecimento e
nós tentamos aplicar ou significar
dentro da sala de aula o que que nós
buscamos aqui a mostrar que dentro da
internet nós conseguimos transformar o
aluno também não ser trico o
conhecimento crítico pode ser obtido
através da cyber cultura se levando em
consideração que saiba cultura é aquilo
que pode ser produzido no universo
virtual porque não algo de forma crítica
para levantar essa criticidade dos
alunos
e aí que tá
e não coloca o peso disso os professores
os professores eles são agentes da
mediação do conhecimento é o professor
que vai mediar o aluno e o saber para
ver se chega até o conhecimento como a
gente disse
é o ideal para essa saída cultura é que
todos nós aqui presentes hoje a possamos
trabalhar como seres produtores dessas
agricultura todo mundo aqui tem celular
todo mundo aqui tem um aparelho
tecnológico independente de qual seja
muitos aqui em são tem grandes
profissões engenheiros médicos advogados
professores cientistas de obras
publicitários porque não a produção
cultural passar da cultura
eu vim para gente ir
e ao invés da gente criticar apenas por
crítica e dizer nossa isso é ruim porque
que você vê isso porque nós não
participamos da produção
e é muito comum haver essa crítica é
muito comum utilizarmos essa ideia de
nada para essa e a gente não faz nada
por si só então o que o aluno vai
continuar vendo fora da escola
e ele vai continuar aquele mesmo
processo cada hora aparece muito bem
diferente falando uma informação
diferente e ele vai consumir aquilo até
quando e não adianta a gente pensa ah eu
estou impedindo não deixa ele ver que
ele vai ver no celular do colega
e ele vai ver as vezes num dia numa sala
de aula professor vai vai passar isso
acontece e
e esse grau que o povo dizendo para
vocês de compartilhamento de
conhecimento chega no nível de
solidariedade a esse pensamento nós
seremos solidários a produção de
conhecimento e dessa forma a gente
pensar no princípio da igualdade do
saber ou seja a gente levar esse saber
ao máximo de pessoas possíveis é branco
de novo essa pergunta não tem fronteira
e dessa forma a gente produzir esse
conhecimento sem a necessidade de ter
alguma barreira
nós temos nossos produtores disso e esta
produção sede livre acesso de qualidade
para que várias pessoas independência
alguma ou não dependentes tem 10 12
cinquenta 60 80 90 anos porque não é se
esse conhecimento produzido com alta
qualidade sair da gente e aí
principalmente pensando nas pessoas que
não tem dinheiro ou não tem tecnologia
para isso eu não estudo uma escola de
elite numa universidade de elite eles
podem ter acesso a esse conhecimento
esse acesso ao conhecimento faz com que
nós reduzimos de forma até sensível
e essa desigualdade social na hora de
apreensão saber
e dessa forma quando nós trabalhamos o
conhecimento dessa desse pensamento
nesse fiesta nós temos o produto
produtores dentro da cyber cultura
porque essa é a função das agricultura
ser modificada produzida e reproduzida a
qualquer momento por qualquer um
e nós chegamos a ideia de que essas
pessoas que não têm acesso constante a
esse tipo de saber
e começar a entender o seu lugar no meio
que vive pensando nos seus direitos e
não seus deveres criando então a ideia
da cidadania
tô pensando direito deveres é uma das
coisas mais difíceis dentro de um país
como o nosso das dimensões continentais
isso
é muita gente não entende o que esse
cidadão e esse compartilhamento do
conhecimento compartilhamento das
informações compartilhamento do saber
nós conseguiremos de forma até básica
não vamos ser muito a pensar muito alto
mas nós conseguimos de forma até simples
alcançar o princípio básico da justiça
social na questão do conhecimento pelo
menos que o conhecimento da distribuição
e livre acesso
oi e aí pensando dessa forma porque
nosso aqui presentes nós e vou disputar
essa palestra que vão ver isso no
youtube porque nosso não podemos ser
esses arquitetos do saber no pontes que
vai ligar essas pessoas ao conhecimento
é porque nós não podemos participar
ativamente desse universo
e daí a gente consegue entender se esse
mundo virtual esse mundo digital que
está presente em nossa vida e que sair
querendo ou não posso conseguimos
entender de forma bem mais clara se ele
vai ser para o bem ou para o mal dessa
forma provavelmente a gente consegue
transformar esse mundo digital um pouco
mais tudo bem obrigado a
e aí
[Música]